هذه الصور التي نشرتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تظهر بحسبها قيام قواتها بصد هجوم
اوكراني ضمن احدى مناطق ما تصفها بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا لم تحدد
المكان بالضبط لكنها في الوقت نفسه تقول
انها تخوض معارك عنيفه للسيطره على وسط
مدينه في شرق اوكرانيا الشيء نفسه تؤكده
حيث نشر الجيش الاوكراني من جهته لقطات
لمظليين بالقرب من خط المواجهه مع القوه
الروسيه
نحن على بعد اقل من كيلومتر من خط
المواجهه مهمتنا هي تحديد مواقع وحدث
العدو وقوته التي يتم ارسالها الى منطقتنا
تحولت بخموت رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه في
مواجهه الروس كييف تامل في استنفاذ قوات
العدو في جميع المناطق الشرقيه كي تصبح في
وضع يمكنها من شن هجوم مضاد واسع كما يقول
الرئيس الاوكراني
سكوديا
ومؤلم جدا يجب علينا تدمير القوه العسكريه
للعدو وسنفعل ذلك في بيلوجوريفكا ومارينكا
وافتيفكا
وجميع الاماكن الاخرى حيث يتوقف مستقبلنا
ومستقبل جميع الاوكرانيين
في وقت سابق اكد قائد مجموعه فاغنر شبه
العسكري الروسيه ان قواته قريبه من وسط
مدينه باغموت لكنه اعترف في الوقت نفسه ان
قوته تواجه مقاومه شرسه قائلا ان
الاوكرانيين يضعون كامله ثقالهم العسكري
في المعركه